hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll and
this believe it or not is the 200th
regular episode of mindscape i say
regular because there's been a lot more
episodes if you count
various bonuses and the ask me anything
episodes and holiday messages and things
like that but 200 is pretty good at
roughly 50 a year that's four years this
is the fourth anniversary of mindscape
so
pretty long compared to many
projects that people launch in various
points of their careers and i've been
very very gratified with all of the
responses from people listening and
hoping that it does some good so i want
to do something to celebrate so i
thought i'd do a solo episode which is
often what i do in these situations and
meanwhile i have going on this shift
from los angeles and caltech to
baltimore and johns hopkins where i will
be a professor of natural philosophy
which is a title that i made up to
indicate that i'll be both doing
philosophy and physics really secretly
it's physics but it's the kind of
physics that fits into a philosophy
department very well there's no boundary
between these two areas right in both
cases you're thinking hard trying to
understand the fundamental workings of
reality that's what i'm interested in
doing so i don't perceive a barrier but
because of various ways in which
academia has evolved over the years
there is a quite a substantial barrier
that other people perceive so i thought
that because this is happening and
because this is the 200th episode for my
solo episode i would talk about
a particular set of issues that count as
natural philosophy in this sense uh the
intersection of physics and philosophy
and furthermore some of the ways in
which physics and philosophy intersect
are pretty
well known you've heard about them
before we've talked a lot about quantum
mechanics and the collapse of the wave
function foundations of quantum
mechanics we've also talked a lot about
time the arrow of time and entropy and
emergence the connections between
fundamental physics and higher levels so
all those things are recognizable
obvious places where both physics and
philosophy have something to say
there's another area which has been
sometimes remarked on but not quite as
much which is cosmology and cosmology is
what i grew up doing as a research
scientist so i'm especially interested
in
philosophical issues in cosmology and
even though it has gotten less attention
it is really a perfectly natural place
for thinking philosophically about
questions in physics because of for
better for worse the fact that the
cosmology problems
that are asking big questions like what
happened at the beginning of the
universe why is there something rather
than nothing things like that
we don't have data on these questions at
least what i should say to be more
slightly more careful is there is no
straightforward path to addressing these
questions just by doing the appropriate
experiment
nevertheless they're important questions
and we should think about them and
therefore we should think carefully
about them there's a tendency to think
sloppily about things in physics
physicists often sort of rely on the
fact that eventually we'll do
experiments and therefore get the right
answer so they can think pretty sloppily
along the way knowing that they're
fundamentally guided by the data
in questions like this that's harder to
do but that doesn't remove our
responsibility to do a good job at it
thinking about the nature of space and
time in the universe so the training the
philosophers have in
digging out our hidden presumptions uh
making sure that we're being logical
along the way things like that make
perfect sense but in fact the philosophy
of cosmology is quite a broad field by
itself so i want to home in on something
very specific which is the philosophy of
the multiverse now when i say that
there's two different things that come
to mind i want to talk about both of
them one is is the multiverse even
physics is it even science right this is
sort of a meta or methodological or
epistemological question about how
science is done does this particular set
of questions count as science it's been
debated to death i will give you my
little perspective on it but i don't
want to dwell too much on it what i
really want to emphasize is beyond those
methodological questions there's a real
ontological question or a set of
questions about how the world actually
works that are at the intersection of
physics of cosmology and philosophy in
particular in the case of the multiverse
how do we reason
if we live in a multiverse how do we
talk about probabilities and where we
are and what our expectations should be
this is one of those things in physics
that is crucially important what do we
expect when we do an experiment right
what do we expect a theory to predict
but usually we're lucky because it's
pretty straightforward answer
and in cosmology in the multiverse in
particular it's not straightforward how
do we think anthropically does it even
make sense to think anthropology all of
these questions that's what i want to
talk about in today's podcast so that's
what i mean in this particular case by
the philosophy of the multiverse and to
me it's a perfect example of this sort
of intersection that we'll be pursuing
at johns hopkins not only myself but
other people as well who are interested
in these sort of interdisciplinary
questions
one other note i wanted to put out there
which is that some people have asked
quite sensibly whether or not the
podcast will keep going at its current
pace given that i have these new
responsibilities and the answer is i
certainly want it to keep going at quite
a
strong pace but i also have to be
realistic i'm going to be teaching i
have other duties that i will have that
i haven't had before
so i've come up with the following
temporary strategy we'll see how this
works which is that at some point i'm
not sure whether it'll be immediately or
in a couple months we'll switch to a
mode where rather than having a podcast
come out every monday
plus an ask me anything episode in the
middle of the month as a bonus i'm just
going to start counting the ask me
anything episodes as regular monday
episodes so i'll still have the numbered
interview plus solo episodes that will
appear on mondays but one of those
mondays during the month we will get an
ask me anything episode the same ask me
anything episodes that i've been doing
but it will be that monday slot so
overall instead of roughly five
podcast episodes per month we'll be
getting four and i think that you know a
little bit of a change but it'll save me
some time and that change
in time savings might be crucially
important uh to my sanity and my ability
to do a good job quality wise with all
things that i'll be doing so we'll see
how it goes who knows maybe i'll find
that i have extra time on my hands and
go back to the previous schedule i'm not
sure it's a it's an experiment that's
what we do in this field um finally for
those of you who are not long time
listeners what i mean by an ask me
anything episode is an episode where
people send in questions and i answer
them but the people in this case are
patreon supporters so if you want to
become a patreon supporter of mindscape
just go to patreon.com
sean m carroll and you sign up for a
dollar a week or a dollar an episode
whatever by the way the ama episodes are
not charged to patreon so the patreons
will be saving a little money because of
this new arrangement because there'll be
one fewer
charged episode per month for the
patreons but the patreons get to ask the
questions and they also get access to
ad-free episodes of the podcast as well
as you know the feeling that they're
doing something right and they're part
of a community that is kind of fun
there's a separate you know conversation
in the comments of the patreon site and
and things like that so if you want to
do that please do i certainly appreciate
the support of the patreons enormously
it helps me
finance various things for the podcast
and it's also just a nice thing but of
course as i always say it's perfectly
okay not to do that especially i know
you know for some people even four or
five bucks a month is an extra outlay
that they don't really want to do that's
perfectly fine anyway i
really appreciate the support 200
episodes in from everyone listening to
mindscape help spread the word help send
it to other people leave reviews on
itunes or wherever you listen to your
podcasts and hopefully we'll be going
for another couple hundred in the future
with that let's go
[Music]
my main goal here really is to bring out
the fact that
this is an area the philosophy of the
multiverse where both physics and
philosophy have both real interests and
real things to say real things to offer
in this discussion and they don't talk
to each other that much to be honest i
mean sometimes philosophers talk about
the multiverse or physics or whatever
but they don't talk to physicists as
much as they should and physicists never
talk to philosophers about these things
because
physicists have this attitude you know
that if they sat down for 15 minutes and
thought about it hard they could figure
it out and
i think that attitude is often not
correct but the point is that today i'm
not necessarily focusing on solving
these problems but just pointing out
that the problems are there that this is
an area where discussions should be had
that we should be open-minded not only
have individual people who are
interested in both sides of the
philosophy physics discussion but have
actual interactions between people on
both sides i do have some opinions about
some of these issues so i will try to
put them forward but i very quickly
admit that my positions are not
completely settled here yet so the
questions are truly open in my mind
let's start by thinking about what we
mean when we say the word multiverse as
you all know
as sophisticated mindscape listeners
there's more than one idea that is
captured by the word multiverse we're
not talking about the multiverse of
movies like doctor strange or everything
everywhere all at once we're talking
about the scientific multiverse but even
there we have different uh ideas in mind
very very different ideas but some of
the same philosophical questions are
common to these scenarios so let's focus
on three kinds i think there are
probably more kinds than this but
there's three
ways in which these multiverse questions
pop up in my work anyway
one is and probably what most working
physicists have in mind when they say
the word multiverse what we might call
the cosmological multiverse and already
it's a bit of a misnomer because the
other so-called universes in the
cosmological multiverse are just regions
of our universe that are very far away
okay the cosmological multiverse is the
idea that we see an observable universe
roughly tens of billions of light years
across and the reason why we can't see
further than that is because there's a
horizon where you look back in time and
you hit the big bang so you can't see
further away than that just because the
speed of light is a finite number one
light year per year
within this observable universe within
the part of the universe that we can see
you know things look pretty smooth
things look pretty uniform over large
scales on small scales there's galaxies
and stars and whatever but if you
average out over millions of light years
you will get a more or less similar
situation in different parts of the
observable universe same number of
galaxies same density of matter all that
stuff
outside the universe we can observe
let's just be honest we don't know
what's gonna happen so we can guess and
that's what we traditionally did in
cosmology the traditional thing in
cosmology was to say well
let's just guess that what happens
outside is more or less a continuation
of what happens inside
and you can do that and then that's
where you get this idea that the
universe is either flat or positively
curved or negatively curved there's
really only three choices
maybe there's some topological
obstruction or something like that or
complications who knows but that idea
that the universe just continued on
indefinitely or maybe for some finite
amount if it was a closed universe
looking just like it does in our
observable universe was always just a
guess there's no principled reason why
it should be that
and if you worry about the multiverse or
you know different copies of yourself as
many people have pointed out
if the universe is spatially flat or
negatively curved and not topologically
twisted up it will be infinite in size
in this simple-minded idea where the
universe is just uniform on large scales
forever
and within our universe if we're just
taking the conditions we see and
extending them indefinitely
the
average density is a number and then
there are fluctuations around that
density and there's kind of only a
finite number of ways
that the number of particles we see in
our observable universe could possibly
have arranged themselves right
it's a big number
a lot of possible ways because we have
something like 10 to the 80th
atoms or massive particles in our
universe another 10 to the 88th photons
and neutrinos and stuff like that so a
lot of particles they could arrange
themselves in a lot of ways but remember
infinity is way bigger than any finite
number
so if you really think that
the universe is the same everywhere on
very large scales so every
patch of universe the size of our
observable universe has roughly 10 to
the 80th atoms in it
and those atoms arrange themselves
differently from place to place but
space goes on infinitely far
then everything that could possibly
happen
will happen in within those universes
within those parts of the universe that
are the size of our observable universe
and there will be an infinite number of
them
so there will be an infinite number of
people exactly like you and me somewhere
else very very very far away in this
infinitely big universe
that right there raises these
philosophical problems of how to deal
with the multiverse because the
philosophical problems i'm going to care
about
are ones that have to do with who are
you in the multiverse which copy of this
person are you how do we reason about
that if there are multiple copies of me
to which everything happens in some
sense how do we make predictions for
anything and none of any of those
questions rely on crazy ideas about
inflation or string theory or quantum
mechanics it's just letting our universe
be infinitely big i think this is one of
the reasons why people like einstein
favored the idea that the universe would
be spatially closed positively curved
and finite in size
um
as far as we know observationally it's
very close to flat
which would be consistent with it going
on for infinity but not it doesn't
demand it you could have a flat universe
that was still wrapped over on itself
like a taurus for example
but anyway as i tried to say the start
there's no principled reason to think
that the universe is the same everywhere
it's just a guess maybe it's true maybe
it's not the idea of the cosmological
multiverse is that it's not
that different regions of space very far
away from each other are really very
different even maybe not only different
densities of matter or different
collections of galaxies and stars but
maybe even different local laws of
physics different things we would use
and recognize as equivalents of the
standard model of particle physics but
with different particles different
forces different strengths of those
forces maybe even different numbers of
dimensions of space time i once wrote a
paper with matt johnson and lisa randall
about how you could dynamically undergo
a transition
from a certain number of dimensions of
space in some region to a different
number of dimensions of space so that
could be part of the cosmological
multiverse
and the crucial thing to
understand about this idea of the
cosmological multiverse is
like will be the same crucial thing to
remember about the other uh versions of
the multiverse is that it wasn't
invented because it sounds cool it
wasn't invented because physicists
thought you know it would be fun to
think about this
we were dragged kicking and screaming
into thinking about the cosmological
multiverse against our will and the
reason why is because the cosmological
multiverse is not a theory
it is a prediction of various theories
and it is a consequence of those
theories but you should judge the
theories that it's a consequence of not
the prediction all by itself you can't
divorce the prediction from the theory
that is making that prediction
in this case the cosmological multiverse
case the theories came about
starting from inflationary theory which
alan guth and others invented circa 1980
and it was driven by an attempt to
understand the data in particular the
data that our universe is smooth
homogeneous and isotropic and also
nearly spatially flat also the fact that
there are no observable magnetic
monopoles in the universe which was a
prediction of various grand unified
theories at the time
so guth used this idea of inflation
which says that if the universe starts
out or at some early time anyway its
energy density is dominated by what we
call a false vacuum energy so much like
today we think since 1998 when we
discovered the universe was accelerating
we think that there is an energy in
empty space a cosmological constant of
vacuum energy but you can also get a
temporary form of vacuum energy or false
vacuum energy which could be really a
lot of energy
in empty space and it would cause the
universe to expand at a hugely
accelerated very fast rate
and that's kind of like pulling the
edges of a wrinkly bed sheet or
something like that it tends to smooth
everything out this super accelerated
expansion
so guth did the physics and he showed
that you could start in this false
vacuum and then you could turn all that
vacuum energy into ordinary matter and
radiation so first you inflate you are
dominated by false vacuum energy you
smooth out the universe and make it flat
and then you convert all that false
vacuum energy into ordinary matter and
radiation now he got it a little bit
wrong but he knew he got it wrong he
pointed out that in his own original
model you never left inflation
you didn't get this nice exit graceful
exit as it was called into a situation
where you've turned that energy into
ordinary matter and radiation so soon
thereafter andre linday and andy
albrecht and paul steinhardt proposed
models where you smoothly rolled a
scalar field down from a high potential
energy to a low potential energy and you
could convert all that energy into
ordinary matter and radiation no problem
so this was called new inflation and it
solved the graceful exit problem but
here's the problem in either old
inflation or new inflation
this scalar field which we posit we
invent it there's no evidence for it yet
but it was posited and it very well
could be related to other ideas in
physics
it's not a classical scalar field right
there is such a thing in the world as
quantum mechanics and so as the scalar
field rolls down its potential and turns
into matter and energy there are quantum
fluctuations it's not absolutely the
same value at different points in space
and that's crucially important that is
the explanation
we think in inflationary universe theory
for the perturbations in density that
give rise to stars and galaxies today we
see the imprint of those quantum
fluctuations in the cosmic microwave
background and in the pattern of
large-scale structure in the universe if
inflation is correct we certainly see
the fluctuations in density and
temperature in the universe inflation
attributes those fluctuations to quantum
fluctuations during the inflationary
period
and people soon thereafter noticed paul
steinhardt andre linde alex flankin and
others
that if you allowed for these quantum
fluctuations you could sometimes have
quantum fluctuations where instead of
rolling down the hill
if you visualize the potential energy of
a scalar field like a hill
uh the field tends to roll down like a
ball rolls down a hill but the quantum
fluctuations say that maybe
you could bounce up the hill
occasionally it's a quantum fluctuation
right it's a rare thing but it could
happen and these potentials are very
flat so it's not that hard to bounce up
the hill and when you bounce up the hill
you now have more energy density
inflation happens faster and you create
more volume of space
so you do the calculation and you show
that for very reasonable values of the
parameters
inflation never really ends
it will end in some region of space but
somewhere else the inflaton field as we
call it this new scalar field that we
invented it quantum fluctuated up the
hill and even though that's relatively
rare when it happens it generates a huge
amount of space because it inflates very
very quickly and then the process
repeats where in that new region that
you've created some places inflation
ends other places it keeps going but
overall it will keep going somewhere in
the universe so this is the idea called
eternal inflation
and it's not necessarily a part of
inflationary theory but it's a very
natural part of inflationary theory it
happens very easily you don't need to
work very hard to make inflation be
eternal so that's already giving you a
kind of a multiverse because it says
that inflation will end where the
inflaton field turns into ordinary
matter and radiation it will end
differently at different points in space
at different times in the history of the
universe but that only became super
exciting when we realized that when
inflation ends the local laws of physics
could be different in different regions
of space and this was something people
had thought about also you know once
again but it became
very on people's minds when we stumbled
across what is called the string theory
landscape
and the string theory landscape was also
in some sense inspired by data once
again when we discovered in 1998 that
the universe is accelerating
we attribute that to a cosmological
constant and this was a revolution this
is the only revolution that i personally
have lived through
in fundamental physics in my time
when we realized that the cosmological
constant was probably not zero because
we all knew that there was an issue here
that the cosmological constant the
energy of empty space
could be anything in principle but you
could estimate what it should be you
could estimate on the basis of effective
quantum field theory what a natural
value for the cos marginal constant
would be and the answer is way way way
bigger than what you actually observe
so
most people when i was in grad school
most people strongly believed that
because the vacuum energy was for some
unknown reason much much much smaller
than it would predicted would be
predicted to be on the basis of
naturalness probably even though we
didn't know what there was some
mechanism that was setting it to exactly
zero because it's just hard to think of
some reason why you should set it so
close to zero and not go all the way
right in the space of all possible
theoretical ideas it was easier to come
up with hypothetical ideas or imagine
that they're there if they just set the
cosmological constant to exactly zero
but then we discovered it's not zero
or at least it doesn't look like it's a
zero it's certainly also possible that
what is causing the universe to
accelerate is something like uh
dynamical scalar field much like
inflation but at a much much lower
energy density that's on the table as a
possibility but uh it's harder to make
that work so you know we don't know yet
we're testing that experimentally once
again but the simplest idea is just that
it's the vacuum energy so back to the
drawing board you know we can't say that
there's some unknown mechanism that sets
the cosmos constant to zero because it's
not zero
and in string theory which was the
leading candidate for quantum gravity um
it certainly was easier to make string
theory work if the cosmos constant was
not positive
in fact it was much much easier to make
it work if the cost of constant is
negative that's a nice way to understand
string theory but if it were zero okay
we could get along with it it was really
hard it remains really hard to
understand why you would have zero
cosmological constant in the string
theory even though you do not have
manifest supersymmetry at low energies
supersymmetry is part of the string
theory toolkit um it's easy enough to
hide it we don't see any evidence for
string theory experimentally but it's
easy enough to hide it just like we hide
other symmetries in physics but in
general when you break super symmetry in
order to hide it you're not left with a
zero cosmological constant it's easy for
it to be negative it's it's hard for it
to be exactly zero it's conjectured to
be easy to be positive but the word easy
is problematic there we don't know uh
there are debates that are still raging
about whether or not the cosmos constant
can indeed be positive in string theory
but again naively it seems that you
could get a positive cosmos constant in
string theory and then once that
possibility was put front and center we
need to understand how the cosmos
constant could be a positive number
people sat down and realized well yeah
we could do that we have all these extra
dimensions of space in string theory
string theory works most naturally
if space time is ten-dimensional
some versions it's 11-dimensional but
but more than four-dimensional okay so
we have to hide those extra dimensions
of space how do we do that we curl them
up into some geometrically interesting
shape and different geometrically
interesting shapes give rise to
different low energy laws of physics
including different values of the
cosmological constant
and this seems at least too many people
to be a natural outcome of string theory
something you didn't need to put in it's
just something that we didn't really
notice or dwell on that much
before the data forced it on us as often
happens in physics okay
so now what you have if you combine
eternal inflation with the string theory
landscape not only do you have inflation
giving rise to many different regions of
universe but string theory says that the
local laws of physics in those regions
might be based on different ways of
compactifying
the extra dimensions of space and that
could give rise to different local laws
of physics including the vacuum energy
so suddenly what you have is different
values of the vacuum energy in different
regions of space
and then you apply an old argument
stephen weinberg made it famous but
other people have pointed out long
before him
namely that if the cosmos constant was
very very big either big and positive or
big and negative it's very hard to
imagine how human beings could exist or
how life could exist because a big
vacuum energy tends to either blow
things apart if it's positive or crunch
the universe in a very short period of
time if it's negative
so there is what we call an anthropic
selection
if and this is a very very big if
if there are many different regions of
space where the vacuum energy is
different it is completely natural so
the story goes to imagine that living
beings only arise in that subset
of all these parts of the universe where
the vacuum energy is not that large and
this would be an explanation for why we
observe a small but not zero vacuum
energy and to be completely historically
accurate steven weinberg pointed this
out ten years before we discovered the
cosmological constant he pointed out
specifically that if
the explanation for the vacuum energy is
not some dynamical mechanism that sets
it equal to zero
but rather some anthropic selection that
says that you know there's many
different values of the vacuum energy
but we only observe the ones that are
compatible with our existence
then you should predict
that the cosmological constant should be
observable it should be small but not so
small that we can't observe it it's just
easier there are more values of the
cosmological constant that are
observable that are not observable even
compatible with our existence and that's
a prediction that he made 10 years
before we actually observed it so that's
a plus in the ledger on the on the plus
side of the ledger for this kind of
reasoning anyway that's the cosmological
multiverse uh that's one of the ways in
which you can get a multiverse and so in
the cosmological multiverse as far as we
know with the kind of calculational
techniques we have there are an infinite
number of universes out there
at least if you include the future as in
the past as well as the present moment
and not only do we have different laws
of physics in many of them but we could
also have exactly the same laws of
physics in some of them
this is a very different idea than the
second scenario we want to talk about
which is the many worlds interpretation
of quantum mechanics
long-time listeners will be familiar
with this so i don't have to do quite as
much detail but many worlds comes about
because we're again trying to explain
the data but the data are very different
data here we're trying to explain the
data of quantum physics the fact that
when you observe the position of an
electron
even though you describe the position of
an electron in terms of a wave function
that is spread out all over space when
you're not observing it when you do
observe it you always see it in a
position you never see the full wave
function what's up with that
there are many different possibilities
for what's up with that the many worlds
possibility says
when you think about that measurement of
you measuring the position of the
electron you really need to think of
yourself as a quantum mechanical system
that has a wave function and when you
model the interaction between you and
the electron that that qualifies as a
measurement what really happens is you
become entangled with the electron so
the reality is not that the electron
collapses to some position according to
many worlds but that there is part of
the wave function that says the electron
was here and you observed it here
another part that says the electron was
over there and you observed it over
there and so on for every possible
measurement outcome and whatever it
proposed is that we take these different
parts of the wave function and treat
them as
separate independent worlds
he had reasons for doing that but i
think that the best reasons post-date
ever the best reasons for
talking about these different parts of
the wave function as completely
independent worlds come down to what we
call decoherence
and decoherence was started in the 70s
people had premonitions of it before
that but really you know the theory was
developed in the 70s and 80s and it
explains why these different worlds
become independent from each other so
that what happens in one world does not
affect anything that happens in another
world so they can't affect each other in
typical circumstances and therefore
that's why we call them other worlds
completely different idea than the
cosmological multiverse the cosmological
multiverse literally has regions that
are far away from each other in space
okay the many worlds of quantum
mechanics literally come into being in
my room when i do a measurement of a
quantum system
i'm not creating a different region of
space far away i'm creating a whole
other parallel universe and it's not
located anywhere they just exist
simultaneously okay the worlds all are
there uh with different amplitudes and
the amplitudes matter if we're talking
about many worlds but we're not talking
about that today we're not talking about
the details of many worlds the point is
that there are many copies of my future
self so there's one copy me right now
there's other copies that have descended
from my past self but here i am right
now i do some measurements there will be
many descendants of my present self in
all of these different worlds so that's
a different kind of multiverse that
appears in physics
and finally there's the idea of
eternally fluctuating cosmologies
which don't have a great name that's why
i will call them eternally fluctuating
cosmologies the idea is the following so
remember back again the
accelerating universe okay so we
discovered in 1998 the universe is
accelerating the easiest explanation for
that is the cosmological constant and
there is a theorem proved back in the
1980s by bob wald at the university of
chicago that says that under pretty
general circumstances
if you have a universe with a positive
cosmological constant and
not too much other stuff
okay then that universe will always
empty out
so if you have other stuff if you have
positive cosmos constant but a lot of
matter so much matter that it curls
space into itself and get a positively
curved universe then that will
eventually re-collapse but if there's
not too much matter so if the universe
is close to flat for example then the
universe expands forever and what
happens is galaxies and other things are
just pulled away from each other all the
density perturbations that we had in the
early universe will flatten out under
the influence of this cosmological
constant accelerated expansion
this is called the cosmic no hair
theorem there's more details you can put
on it because the galaxies have dynamics
they have stars in them the stars will
burn out fall into black holes the black
holes will evaporate the evaporating
radiation from the black holes will be
redshifted to essentially non-existence
and then you're really left with nothing
but empty space and the name of this
empty space with nothing in it but
vacuum energy is called descender space
after willem de sitter the astronomer
who first solved einstein's equations
and found this cosmological solution
one of the things i love about this
cosmic no-hair theorem that all
universes with the positive cosmological
constant evolve toward deceiter space
just like all black holes evolve towards
just mass charge and spin
black holes
is that
like the black hole case there's an
entropy interpretation here right
whenever you have a system that
inevitably evolves towards some
macroscopic state and then just sits
there forever that sounds like
increasing entropy
thermalization
approach of the system to equilibrium
so i had long conjectured that this
cosby no hair theorem was probably
equivalent
to
equilibration to entropy increase to the
second law of thermodynamics and finally
with a graduate student aiden chatwin
davies i was able to prove that aiden
did most of the proving i got i got to
admit but we basically uh found a
definition of entropy that applied to
these cases and we showed that even
without
einstein's equation of general
relativity if you just had an expanding
universe with a certain definition of
entropy and you conjectured that the
entropy in a region approached a maximum
value then stayed there forever that
would be equivalent to the sitter space
to this exponentially expanding
accelerating universe
so that's
the standard model of our universe okay
so i'm not making anything up about
inflation or string theory or anything
i'm teasing about making things up i'm
not speculating uh this is the
most commonly
accepted view of what our actual
universe is doing it's accelerating
because there's a cosmological constant
it's conceivable that cosmological
constant will disappear sometime in the
future but we don't know
and it's conceivable there won't okay so
the easiest thing is that the universe
just expands forever under the influence
of that cosmological constant in which
case we will approach to sitter space
and again just like black holes the
sitter space has a horizon and a
temperature and an entropy and this was
all figured out by stephen hawking and
gary gibbons back in the 1970s so just
like a black hole gives off a little bit
of radiation
there is a sense in which
decider space is a thermal state a black
body state a state with the
physical characteristics of a body at a
fixed temperature and the temperature is
going to be very low you know we think
about the cosmic microwave background
out there today at about 2.7 kelvin okay
this is going to be oh forget the
numbers unfortunately i think it's
something like 10 to the minus 35 kelvin
when we eventually reach uh
the descender equilibrium in our future
i forget the exact number is that the
right number i really don't know maybe
10 to the minus 30. but way way lower
than the current temperature of the
cosmic microwave background
but just as with the classic universe
that is just infinitely big the dissider
universe is infinitely old right it
lasts forever under this some simple way
of thinking about it
so if you have a dissident universe that
lasts forever there is a sense and this
is an argument this is less clear than
other things i've said so let me just
say the argument and then i'll sort of
give you the caveats to it it's a little
bit like
a box of gas at a fixed temperature that
lasts forever okay so if you have a box
of gas at a fixed temperature that lasts
forever you have a bunch of particles
running around inside bumping into each
other and mostly for most of the time
they will sit there in their highest
entropy state but just due to random
fluctuations occasionally
the thermal fluctuations inside the box
of gas will lead to an entropy decrease
there will be a fluctuation downward in
entropy to a more orderly configuration
and then it will relax back and
sometimes you know you can actually
calculate how much of an entropy
fluctuation you expect and the answer is
you will get all sorts of fluctuations
if you wait long enough
so a very standard thing to torture
undergraduates with is calculate how
long you would have to wait for all of
the air in the room in the classroom
that we have right now to move over to
one side of the classroom and leave the
students on the other side gasping for
breath okay it's many many times the
current age of the universe not
something you have to worry about but it
will happen if you thought that your
classroom would last forever and the
probability of such a fluctuation
is
bigger for small fluctuations smaller
for big fluctuations okay that should
make sense a tiny fluctuation away from
equilibrium will be much much more
likely than a huge crazy fluctuation
away from equilibrium so it's much more
likely that the gas in the room goes
onto one half of the room than it is
that all the gas in the room shrinks
down to one little cubic centimeter in
the corner of the room both will happen
but the medium-sized fluctuation happens
much more often than the huge
fluctuation
and this of course this way of thinking
if the sitter space is like this
if the future of our universe is a
thermally fluctuating box of gas
then you will eventually fluctuate
downward in entropy and you will
fluctuate so much that you know
sometimes you'll have a couple of
particles appear out of the vacuum
a couple of times more rarely you'll
have a few particles appear with high
energies and bump into each other and
make you know atoms
if you wait long enough you'll have
enough stuff fluctuating fluctuate into
existence that it makes molecules or
macroscopic
amounts of stuff i mean if you wait long
enough you'll fluctuate into stars and
planets and galaxies or even the whole
universe i wrote a whole nother paper
about that with matt johnson and anthony
aguirre anthony of course was a previous
mindscape guest
and uh so it will happen if you wait
long enough and the dissider future of
our universe is supposed to last
infinitely long so you'll get all sorts
of these fluctuations and that leads to
the boltzmann brain problem the idea is
that if you had
some reason to believe
that
you are a typical observer in the
universe well what does a typical
observer in this universe look like it
looks like a random fluctuation right
most observers you know you get who
knows how many billions or trillions of
observers like you and me after the big
bang but that you get an infinite number
of observers that are random
fluctuations in the future so who cares
about us
living right after the big bang most
observers in this situation are going to
be random fluctuations
that causes a philosophical problem
which is exactly what we're going to get
to in a second
before i get to that um let me just
mention that we're not sure by any means
that even if our universe does settle
down to an empty deceiter-like phase
there will be
these random fluctuations because
there's a tricky interplay between
quantum mechanics and gravity going on
here i wrote a paper with kim body and
jason pollock where we explained that in
a very natural set of assumptions
where the hilbert space of quantum
gravity is infinite dimensional if you
don't know any of those words mean don't
worry about it some of you who followed
for a long time will know what they mean
but it's basically a fancy way of saying
if an arbitrarily large number of things
can happen in the universe
then that actually lets the universe
settle down into a static quantum state
so what what happens in that case is
that you interpret the statement that
dissider is a thermal state as saying
that if you were to make a measurement
of it then you would measure if you had
a thermometer there literally which you
can't because you're not in empty sitter
space because you're a thing you're not
emptiness but anyway if you had a
thermometer there you would measure a
thermal spectrum of photons but in the
many worlds interpretation there's a
difference between what is happening
when you're not measuring the thing
where it's just a wave function versus
what you observe when you physically
interact with it in order to measure it
and the point is that when you're not
measuring it when there's nothing
disturbing the state there's also
nothing happening there's no dynamical
fluctuations the thermalness of this
quantum state is a statement of what you
would observe but not a statement about
the dynamical things coming and going
like brains coming into existence or
anything like that
by the way i forgot to finish the
boltzmann brain story the reason why
they're called boltzmann brains is
because a typical observer would not
just be a random fluctuation
but the typical random fluctuation would
be we expect the minimum fluctuation
needed to count
as an observer in this universe that's
because there's more ease way easier to
get small fluctuations in entropy than
large ones so the idea is that the
minimum observer is just a brain you
randomly fluctuate into existence of
brain which looks around says huh
thermal equilibrium and then it dies
then it goes back into it dissolves back
into the surrounding thermal equilibrium
and the argument by some people says
well we're not a boltzmann brain
therefore that can't be the world and
the issue here is that this is not some
speculative scenario about the early
universe this is
the most popular view of our actual
universe and so that's a real problem so
the paper that kim and jason and i wrote
tried to say that it's easy to avoid
this problem
if you make certain assumptions about
quantum gravity but of course we don't
know those assumptions are true so it's
still very very worth thinking about
these ideas okay
so that's three different versions of a
physics oriented multiverse the
cosmological multiverse the many worlds
of quantum mechanics and an eternal
fluctuating cosmology the eternal
fluctuating cosmology is a kind of a
multiverse in time it's not like
different regions of space are different
universes but if you wait long enough
whatever kind of universe you want to
think about will fluctuate into
existence so it is effectively a
multiverse
one thing to emphasize which i've noted
all along is that every single one of
these three options is a consequence of
other ideas it is not put forward for
its own sake and it's a consequence of
other ideas that were
proposed in order to account for data
in order to explain the universe that we
see okay so it is 100
the standard scientific process going on
here there's in no sense
some diversion or distraction away from
doing real science by thinking about
these different multiverses nevertheless
not everyone agrees people object uh
there are people out there who don't
like these discussions of multiverses
and you know to be honest it gets
weirdly emotional
people get very angry talking about the
multiverse on both sides you know on all
sides i should say
they talk to each other about being
unscientific and they get kind of ad
hominem and name-cally and it's really
kind of tiresome and that's why that's
kind of what i don't want to talk about
here today i don't want to dwell on the
question of
does talking about these scenarios count
as science i feel what i want to do is
dig into how to talk about these
scenarios if you think that it is okay
to do it but i need to very quickly
comment
on this issue of is it doing science is
it science at all to talk about the
multiverse
um
the
all too easy objection to the multiverse
is that it's not falsifiable right
famously sir carl popper philosopher of
science proposed the falsifiability
criterion to demarcate scientific
theories from non-scientific theories
now almost none of the physicists who
bring up falsifiability have actually
read what karl popper wrote but they
carry on their shoulder a little straw
popper that they have simplified down to
this motto that says if you can't
falsify the theory through an experiment
then it's not science that's not what
popper said that's certainly not what
philosophers of science believe they
don't even believe that falsifiability
works at all generally most of them as a
demarcation between science and
non-science but popper was on to
something the real pauper he did have
good reasons to be to propose this
criterion even if i don't think that it
actually gives you the final answer
um
he cared about having theories that were
definite that said something okay so he
was worried about theories that he
thought like
uh marxist analyses of history or
freudian psychoanalysis in popper's mind
i'm not going to make any statement
about whether i agree with this or not i
haven't really thought about it but in
his mind
literally anything could happen
and advocates of marxist history or
freudian psychoanalysis could after the
fact tell a story to purportedly explain
it okay so he was really worried about
the fact that these theories didn't have
any content
to them
and that's why he proposed
falsifiability because he said look if
you could say if anything
happening in the in the world is
explicable in terms of your theory
anything that could possibly happen
is explicable then your theory has no
explanatory value
that is not the worry in the case of the
multiverse okay though all these
different multiverse scenarios are
absolutely
undisputably saying something than
saying not other things okay
the problem is that what they're saying
happens in the universe are things that
we can't see things that we can never in
principle see we can never touch the
other worlds of the many worlds theory
we can never see the cosmological
multiverse we can never notice the
boltzmann brains coming into existence
tens of tens of tens of 10 to the 10 to
the 10 billion years in the future or
whatever so
it's saying something definite but you
don't know you're not going to be able
to test it in any simple way so should
we count it as science well of course we
should and popper i think would agree
with me about this because he had
different fish to fry the basic issue is
that these scenarios could be true
right
and
that really could be the way nature
works and that's a difference with what
popper was worried about there really
could be other universes out there
elsewhere in the wave function or in
space or in time
and the reason why it matters is because
whether or not there are these other
universes affects how we do science here
in this universe trying to explain the
data that we have in our observable part
of the universe when you do cosmology or
when you do these large-scale scenarios
to explain the universe things are
connected to each other they are
interrelated we talk about the
multiverse and things we can't observe
but the reason why we talk about them is
because they play an explanatory role in
what we do observe and this is just
science this is not anything new i'm not
in the camp that says we need to like
think about a new paradigm for doing
science because of the multiverse it's
exactly the same paradigm we always had
we come up with a theory we use it to
account for the data okay
so
for example in the cosmological
multiverse
we
we invoke the cosmological multiverse as
an explanation for the observed value of
the vacuum energy and possibly for the
observed values of other constants of
nature like the mass of the higgs boson
and so forth to account for the apparent
mysterious numbers that we observe in
physics the fine-tuning of certain
parameters that was what stephen
weinberg tried to do before we even knew
the cosmological constant was not zero
and so the point is if you're a working
physicist and you say i would like to
understand why the vacuum energy has a
value it does
whether or not
you think that the cosmological
multiverse is a promising theory
absolutely indisputably affects what
kind of theoretical
ideas you will consider and put forward
right if you don't think that multiverse
makes sense or is there
then it is beholden on you to come up
with some dynamical mechanism that
explains why the cosmos constant has the
value we observe
if you do think that the multiverse is
there then arguably you don't need to do
that it's just an environmental
selection effect other you can't have a
dynamical theory that predicts with
probability one that the cosmos constant
has a certain value and think that's a
good theory if it has other values
elsewhere right so how you do science is
affected by whether or not you take this
particular theory seriously
likewise for the many worlds of quantum
mechanics again you're trying to do
science we science is not done physics
does not have the theory of everything
yet you're trying to build on what we
currently know
and how you do that will be dramatically
affected by your attitude towards the
foundations of quantum mechanics if you
don't believe many worlds many worlds
just comes out of thinking that there's
a wave function or a quantum state that
obeys the schrodinger equation if you
don't believe that you need to tell me
either
what there is in addition to the wave
function or why and how the wave
function doesn't obey the schrodinger
equation that's extra work you got to do
if you don't believe in the many worlds
of quantum mechanics tell me what the
hidden variables are tell me what the
explicit objective collapse rule is if
you believe in those kinds of things
again your practice of science is
affected by the
reasonability of this multiverse
scenario and finally again likewise for
the fluctuating cosmology the eternal
fluctuating cosmology scenarios because
how do you account for the big bang in
its low entropy state that will matter
that will be affected by if you think
our universe is eternal and fluctuating
what do you think will happen in the
future to our universe also effects is
affected by how you think about these
scenarios
so
in my mind of course it is science it's
not a close call it's not like you know
quasi science it's hard
that's true that's okay
i'm not saying that i can tell you some
easy straightforward experiment that i
can imagine to do which will once and
for all
reveal whether one of these multiverses
exists or not
but nobody ever promised you a rose
garden just because i can't think of an
experiment which will help us change our
credences to either close to zero or
close to one doesn't mean it's not
science sometimes science is just going
to be hard sometimes we will be left in
the dark for maybe a long time about
what is the correct scenario
but there is something that is true
about what the universe looks like
outside our horizon what the wave
function of the universe looks like
overall and so forth so therefore in my
mind it is completely science
having said all that
i think that and this is always a
dangerous angle to take when you start
to um
probe the psychology of people you don't
agree with but uh i want to give people
credit here a little bit i think that
the anxiety
that uh is centered on multiverse
scenarios does arise out of a perfectly
legitimate worry
and the worry is how do you think about
our place in the universe in such cases
okay so this is fundamentally a
philosophical problem like there's just
no question this is what philosophers
were trained to do and often there are
philosophy papers written about problems
that are typically not phrased in
down-to-earth cosmological terms but
nevertheless utterly relevant to them
um that address the question of what
credence should we have for these
different questions credence being a
degree of belief how confident are we
that these things are true and in
particular there's actually two
different sets of credences we need to
think about one is the standard
scientific question of which theory is
correct okay which theory is there a
multiverse cosmological multiverse or
not is many worlds correct or is you
know bohmian mechanics correct or
something like that is the
hilbert space of quantum gravity finite
dimensional or infant dimensional
down-to-earth questions about what is
the physics underlying what's going on
so that's a credence that we all have as
working scientists for these different
models and we would like to adjust them
according to bayes's theorem
in the correct way
but there's also a different credence
that comes in
and that's why
even though there's always some
philosophy of science involved in doing
science here the philosophy of science
is sort of more interesting and fun
because the other credence is
who are we in the universe
in other words these are multiverse
scenarios that have a lot of people in
them
if it's the cosmological multiverse we
have different regions of space possibly
an infinite number with different laws
of physics but some of them will have
the same laws of physics and we can
imagine there's a wide variety of
different kinds of intelligent observers
in them how do we place ourselves within
that huge set of different numbers of
observers in the case of many worlds
it's a very down-to-earth and very
in-your-face version of this question
when the wave function branches and
there are now two different versions of
the observer who made the measurement
what probability do they assign to being
on the spin up or spin down branches of
the wave function of the universe that
they've measured the spin of some
electron that is the problem of deriving
the born rule in the many worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics
which version are you
um chip stevens my caltech colleague and
i wrote a paper about this uh where we
called it self-locating uncertainty or
sometimes people also call it indexical
uncertainty
it's not just there are many observers
in the universe there are multiple
copies of the same kind of observer
they're different because once on one
branch of the wave function one's on the
other but they're identical except for
where they're located in the universe
that's self-locating uncertainty which
one are you
and finally for the boltzmann brain
eternally fluctuating universe scenario
right um
are you a boltzmann brain are you sure
are you a boltzmann something else or
are you
really really confident that you're an
ordinary observer and if so does that
lead you to reject the hypothesis that
there are boltzmann brains at all okay
all very good questions all questions
that require
careful philosophical analysis and
again just to be a little bit
editorializing here you know one of the
reasons why it's fun and interesting and
also productive to get physicists and
philosophers talking to each other is
because they have different kinds of
blind spots i would say i love them both
some of my best friends are physicists
and or philosophers but they have
different things they're really good at
and different things they're not so good
at philosophers are really good at
telling you why your theory is wrong
i mean to put it in more careful terms
philosophers are good at analyzing the
logical chain of reasoning that leads
you to some conclusion and telling you
you know where you messed up like you
made a leap here that isn't quite okay
physicists just want to get the right
answer and over and over again in the
history of physics they get the right
answer for the wrong reasons right you
know the data always save you in physics
you will eventually get the right answer
no matter how bad your reasoning is
because the data are just not going to
let you continue to get it wrong over
and over and over again this is exactly
the case where when you get to the
multiverse you're going to get in
trouble
because you know with something like
quantum field theory you know you write
down the quantum field theory it's in
the 1930s or 40s and you get an infinite
answer
and if you didn't have any data you
might just say well this is bad theory
is wrong answer is infinite the data
said you couldn't get away with that you
needed to do something about it so you
did a lot of work to understand
renormalization and getting rid of the
infinities and so forth even the
invention of quantum mechanics is an
example just like that where there was
just so much data forcing you to these
crazy conclusions
but the multiverse you can reason very
sloppily about it
and think that you're on the right track
because there's no immediate experiment
that is guiding you to the correct
answer right that's exactly where
philosophers uh are very helpful that is
their strong point
their weak point uh in my mind is that
they care less about getting the right
answer then the right reasoning that
that gets you to whatever answer you're
getting
that's a slightly overly harsh way of
saying it but the way that it shows up
in practice is there's a lot of
philosophical effort put into
working out the consequences of
theoretical constructs that in my mind i
would say we know are not right
you know quantum field theory is a very
good theory but it's probably not the
right answer for what nature does
because it doesn't really play well with
gravity
general relativity is a very good theory
of gravity classically but it's not the
final answer for gravity because it
doesn't play well with quantum mechanics
and there's a lot of my philosophy
friends who just put a lot of effort
into understanding consequences at the
very very detail level of these theories
because it's a fun little puzzle you
know of logic etc but to me it's not
actually helping us understand nature
that well so i i
rely on philosophers to tell me where my
chain of reasoning is wrong uh but
they're not as good at
picking out a better theory and that's
what physicists are very good at so
that's why we need both in the case of
the multiverse okay editorializing over
um
to the problem that we're facing with
you can think about it in terms of
bayesian inference right bayesian
reasoning
we have bayes's rule for those of you
who don't know it baze's rule is a way
of saying i have some propositions
some are going to be true some are going
to be false let's pick a set of
propositions that are mutually exclusive
so they can't all be true at the same
time like there is a cosmological
multiverse or there's not okay or i am
this branch of the wave function or i'm
some other branch of the wave function
well bayes gives you a way of updating
that the probability the credence really
that you put on these different
propositions when new information comes
in when new data comes in as we usually
say
and basis rule says that the probability
of any given theory
given the new data
is proportional to the probability of
what the probability you would have to
get that data if the theory were true
times the original prior probability of
the theory okay so you have some prior
probability on all the different
propositions like this multiverse or
that multiverse you say if these
different propositions were true what's
the probability the likelihood as we
call it that i would get some data you
multiply those together and that tells
you the probability of your theory now
that you have that data
and the problem we're facing with here
is
what exactly do you mean by the
likelihood function of bayesian analysis
the likelihood is what is the
probability you would see that data if
this theory were true okay
and unfortunately or fortunately the
data we're talking about is i exist
that's the data okay
what is the probability that i would
exist or you would exist if you can go
ahead and do it yourself
that we would exist in this cosmological
scenario
what does that mean exactly i mean is it
the probability that
intelligent observers exist or would
exist in this scenario or is it the
probability that observers like me or
exactly like me really exist
and do i have to like exist with certain
other features or anywhere in the
universe etc in fact this is a
well-known problem in bayesian reasoning
called the problem of old evidence
does something that we've known about
all along some evidence that we've had
from the start
really help us update our priors does it
provide extra evidence
so does the fact that you and i are here
thinking about this
count as evidence for anything
i mean obviously if you have a
cosmological scenario where i could not
exist then i should give that a credence
of zero you know
my existence is a very well known fact
but can i pretend not to know that
write down all the cosmological
scenarios and then update the credences
i have on them using bayes's rule and
with the data that i do exist
i don't know can i do that like is that
okay or
did the fact that i exist
already go into me making up these
credences in the first place so i
shouldn't count it twice that's the
problem
and then furthermore at a slightly more
detailed level you know if i say okay i
exist
is that supposed to favor a scenario
where i would exist with probability 0.9
over a scenario where i would exist with
probability 0.1
maybe probably i mean that seems
reasonable but okay now what about this
one
what about
comparing a universe where there is
exactly one person like me
with another universe where there is a
huge number a billion quintillion people
exactly like me
in both universes the probability that
someone like me exists is one
but there's more of people like me in
the other universe so should i count
that should i give that a bonus should i
count that as extra evidence in favor of
that cosmological scenario
i'm not sure this is the question this
is what we're trying to address right
here right now so let me finally
you know whenever i get the solo podcast
i just can't help talking and keep
talking for a long time so i'm finally
now introduction over ready to talk
about what we're actually here to talk
about how do we
think about probabilities and credences
in these multiverse theories and this is
a question for the philosophy of
cosmology and it's look i'm not
pioneering this this question people
have certainly worried about this quite
a bit
and there is a standard strategy uh for
dealing with this which is to say
something like the following
we should reason as if
we are typical in some reference class
of observers okay so the idea is this is
called the principle of typicality or
the principle of mediocrity right or the
copernican principle like the idea is
that we're not special in the universe
and the motivation comes from the
anthropic principle from thinking about
this question allah weinberg if you had
many many different parts of the
universe with let's say different values
of the cosmological constant how do you
use that to make a prediction for what
you should observe
and the idea is you say well there's
many observers in this collection this
ensemble you know some of them might
live in
high
values of the cosmological constant
parts of the universe others might live
in low values whatever there's some
distribution there's some number that
you could figure out
and i should not according to this
reasoning think of myself as special i'm
a typical observer in this and so i
predict that i should observe what a
typical observer in this ensemble should
see okay that's the idea of typicality
mediocrity copernican principle whatever
you want to call it and
i think that
some version numb two things number one
some version of this idea is more or
less universally accepted among modern
cosmologists this is how modern
cosmologists think if they think about
it at all like i'm putting aside the
people who just don't think it's science
to talk about the multiverse within
multiverse theorists this idea that we
should presume were typical is more or
less a consensus um and number two
i don't think it's very well defined or
very good idea at all i think we need to
do better that's why we're here having
this conversation so why am i worried
about this well number one
why
are we typical why are we supposed to
think that we're typical observers i
mean to me it's perfectly obvious that i
am not a typical observer even among
people here on earth
most people on earth don't have podcasts
there you go that's one of the very
large number of ways in which i am not a
typical observer so isn't that evidence
against this so-called principle of
reasoning that you are putting forward
um and even more
importantly and a more technical level
i'm typical within
precisely what class of observers
like all
living beings
do bacteria count or do they have to be
really conscious like what level of
consciousness do i need to count as a
typical observer in this
scenario like what if there's a hive
mind what if there's the borg do they
count as one observer or they count as
do i get count them separately for all
the different biological entities that
went into making them up do i count
artificial observers do i count uh
artificial intelligences in silicon in
the simulation in the matrix
these are all important questions that
are not immediately addressed so this is
called the reference class problem in
these um in this sort of principle of
typicality way of thinking let's put all
that aside i'm gonna be very very
generous for the moment i'm gonna say
okay forget about the reference class
problem that's something to keep in mind
it should bug us
it seems that you know you're proposing
a fundamental principle of reasoning
that is tremendously ill-defined that
should worry you but let's assume you
can figure it out let's assume that's a
technicality
and
i would say nevertheless that this is
not we're not done yet
just to say we're typical in some
reference class of observers isn't quite
enough to let us make the next step and
turn this into
given a cosmological scenario what
probabilities do i predict
so to make this down to earth i'm gonna
i can't draw pictures there's an audio
podcast but i want you to imagine two
different universes okay
universe a and universe b universe a is
a small universe by which i mean there
are relatively few observers there's
maybe you know maybe it doesn't have to
be when i say relatively few maybe it's
like the universe we see right with
billions of galaxies in it and so forth
but nothing outside not an infinite
amount of extra stuff
that's universe a small universe and
then there's a big universe universe b
is big and it's you know physically in
many ways like the small universe a but
it's just bigger so there's many many
many more observers in universe b than
in universe a okay so we have two
numbers
for each scenario and when i talk about
these universes i should should try very
hard to get the vocabulary right these
are two different theories not really
two different universes these are two
different theories of the cosmological
whole shebang the whole ensemble so
theory a
has relatively few observers everywhere
in the multiverse
theory b has many many many observers in
the multiverse okay and so they come
attached with both the number of
observers in them n a and n b but then
also our prior probabilities we're going
to try to be good bayesians we're going
to try to say like
what do the observations tell us about
these two cosmological scenarios should
we give more
likelihood to theory a or theory b okay
and so there's a prior probability
that's based on you know questions of
simplicity and fruitfulness and how well
it fits in with other things we know
about physics
probability the prior probability of
scenario a and scenario b
then how do you reason
in this set of questions you know how
should we update our priors when new
data comes in
and there's actually out there so even
though i said
almost every multiverse cosmologist
believes some kind of version of the
principle of typicality they employ it
in very different ways and in fact
there's two different ways roughly
speaking to two big popular camps uh for
dealing with this one is more popular
than the other but
and they have terrible names one is
called the self-sampling assumption or
ssa and the other is called the
self-indication assumption or s-i-a we
talked about these a little bit in the
podcast with nick bostrom some while ago
he is
partly responsible for this nomenclature
so
i honestly struggle because when you say
ssa self-sampling assumption and s-i-a
self-indication assumption
those words
imply nothing in my brain i have no idea
which is supposed to be which so i've
re-christened them
uh think about them as the world first
versus observer first approaches okay so
the world first approach says you
assign your prior probability to each
world each scenario right
scenario a or scenario b and then inside
each scenario you assume we are a
typical observer right so that's a very
sensible thing to do you have your first
year prior that the theory is right then
within the theory you assign you assume
that you're typical but notice what this
is doing if you had in theory a and
theory b the same prior probability
right they were equally likely a priori
but
there was only one observer like you in
your reference class in in theory a and
who knows 10 to the 100 observers like
you in theory b
then the probability that you are that
observer in theory a is 50
and the probability that you are any one
of the observers in theory b is 50 times
10 to the minus 100.
so you see what's going on it's like a
non-trivial move you're much more likely
to be that particular single observer in
the small universe scenario given these
assumptions the world first approach
then you are any one of the observers in
the big universe but the total
probability you're in the big universe
is assumed to be equal under this set of
assumptions
that's the self-sampling assumption okay
ssa when other people out there
talk about the self-sampling assumption
they mean the world first approach to
assigning probabilities assign a prior
to the scenario to the world then assume
you're typical within it
the other approach the self-indication
assumption is what i call the observer
first approach
and this is a bit of a move here you
know you can we'll argue about it but
people do um it's to say assume you're
typical within the set of all observers
and what that means is effectively so
all observers in all of the different
scenarios assume that you are typical
and effectively and you can you need to
do some extra work to make that work at
a quantitative level because if you had
different priors for the different
cosmological scenarios then
how do you make how do you mean to
assign yourself typicality within that
ensemble of all of them but you can do
it you can do the math you can run the
numbers
the point of this move even though it
seems a little bit counter-intuitive is
if you have a cosmological scenario with
more observers in it
then you should think that that scenario
is more likely to produce an observer
like you
right because there's just more ways so
if you if you don't say that these
observers were considering our reference
class are exactly like you let's just
say we have the reference class of all
intelligent observers right
and in universe a there's literally one
intelligent observer
and we don't know it's like a human-like
observer maybe it's an octopus or a gas
bag in uh the clouds of jupiter or
something right
and in scenario b there's 10 to the 100
intelligent observers
the argument would be that even if on
physics grounds you had equal
prior probability for scenario a and
scenario b
given that you are a human being with
certain characteristics and so forth
it's just easier to imagine someone just
like you coming into existence
in the universe scenario with more
observers in it so we should count that
more and the way that we do that in this
observer-first approach the
self-indication assumption is
effectively to boost the prior
probability by the number of observers
in your reference class so roughly
speaking world first says give your
prior probabilities to all the different
scenarios and then assume you're typical
within them
observer first says
assume that you're somehow typical in
the space of all observers in all
possible worlds and therefore favor
those scenarios with more observers in
them okay
and uh bostrom himself as well as people
like brandon carter and alex vlankin
have argued for the world first approach
um uh ken olum and others have argued
for the observer first approach so
they're both people arguing for these
approaches
now
do the philosophers have anything to
tell us about this
well yes what philosophers are really
good at is setting up a problem
logically and clearly and then
disagreeing about how to solve it
so there is a problem that if if you are
a philosopher or you know
philosophically um adjacent
these words i've been telling you about
small universe a big universe b
assigning priors to them
will very strongly remind you of a very
well-known problem in philosophy called
the sleeping beauty problem which i
believe was first put in these words by
adam elga aplos for princeton and so the
sleepy beauty problem is the following
and it's nothing to do with cosmology
but you'll see what the connection is
right away
so this is
a thought experiment you don't really do
this you would never get approval from
the
institutional research board to do this
experiment but the idea is
you have a test subject sleeping beauty
where you are going to put to sleep
and then wake up and ask a question okay
and what happens is you put sleeping
beauty to sleep and then you flip a coin
and sleeping beauty knows exactly
what the
experimental protocol is going to be and
the experimental protocol is the
following you flip a coin after she's
asleep
it's going to be heads or tails and it's
a fair coin so it's what you would
ordinarily assign 50 50 credence to 50
50 for heads versus tails
if the coin comes up heads
then you put her to sleep on monday on
sunday sorry on monday you wake her up
if it came up heads and you say what is
your credence that the coin came up
heads
but if the coin came up tails
then you wake her up monday you ask her
that question and then you put her back
to sleep
and you wipe her memory this is why you
would never get approval to do this in
the real world and you wake her up again
on tuesday and you ask her the question
again so the difference is if the coin
came up heads you only wake her up once
well you will wake her up on wednesday
in either case and you know let her live
her life but you do the experiment where
you wake her up and ask her about the
credence that its heads only wants on
monday if it is heads if it was tails
you will wake her up and ask that
question twice once on monday once on
tuesday okay
and the question is
when she is awakened and asked this
question what is your credence that the
coin is came up heads what should she
say what is the rational thing to say
and i believe that um
well there's two possible there's two
ways of thinking about it there is
the idea which elga originally argued
for in his paper which says that
even though it's a 50 50 coin when
sleeping beauty wakes up she doesn't
know whether it's monday or tuesday she
doesn't know whether it's been heads or
tails and she should give a one-third
probability one-third credence to the
question did the head did the coin come
up heads
why well imagine that you changed the
experiment a little bit and you told her
if it was monday okay
so now you're saying if it you wake her
up
if it's heads and monday you say it's
monday what's the probability was heads
if it's tails and monday you say
it's tails and monday sorry yeah it's
monday what is the probability was tails
or heads
and if it's tuesday you say up never
mind it's tuesday okay this doesn't
count well in that case she knows that
it's monday and there's a 50 50 chance
of being heads or tails and it's the
same either way if it's monday there's
no extra thing going on so therefore
it's 50 50. right or sorry i shouldn't
say i should i skipped ahead
she should give equal credences
to it being heads or being tails if she
knows it's monday right because
conditionalized on knowing that it's
monday there's an equal probability that
the coin came up heads or the coin came
up tails
but you can also
use the same logic says elga if you tell
sleeping beauty that the coin came up
tails and ask her is it monday or
tuesday right if the coin came up tails
she's going to be awakened twice they're
completely identical situations she
should have equal credences for it being
monday or tuesday and therefore you have
equal credences for tales and monday
tales and tuesday and heads end monday
there's only one way to make three
numbers equal which is to make them
one-third each
i don't know whether or not that was a
very clear explanation of the point you
can wikipedia it's there or you can read
elga's original paper um i think this is
a very sensible this is a perfectly
reasonable thing to say because you know
think about just doing the experiment
over and over again right and think
about making bets with sleeping beauty
you know is did are you going to bet
that it was heads or tails
you'll be making bets twice as often
with versions of sleeping beauty where
the thing came up tails right because
there she will be awakened both monday
and tuesday and therefore the way to
break even for sleeping beauty
is to assign equal probabilities to each
of the three possibilities heads tales
monday tails tuesday that's the thirder
possibility
but then david lewis comes along a
famous philosopher who passed away a
while ago and lewis said no no
before she goes to sleep on sunday
sleeping beauty would assign a credence
of 50 50 to the coin coming up heads or
tails
and when you wake her up
she gains no new information in the
original version of the experiment she's
not told whether it's monday or tuesday
so she's just awakened and she should
stick by her guns and still say that the
creedence for the coin coming up heads
or tails is 50 50. you don't learn
anything new
okay so
most of us
would say that the thirder position is
probably a bit more
reasonable bit more intuitive anyway
whether it's right or not again people
argue back and forth david lewis adam
algo both very smart people um
but think about what's going on um the
thirder position
is basically saying i give even even
though my prior probability for the head
for the tails
for the coin coming up heads or tails
was 50 50. if i know that in the tails
universe
there will be two copies of me one that
woke up monday one that woke up tuesday
and in the heads universe there is only
one copy of me
if i'm giving equal probability to all
three of those ideas that's the observer
first approach
the observer first approach in cosmology
the self-indicating assumption
was assume we are typical in the set of
all observers
in all different universes the analogy
is that the different universes are a
universe where the head with a coin
comes up heads and the universe where
the coin comes up tails a scenario a
scenario where it's heads a scenario
where it's tails right
if you just stuck with the world first
approach
you assign it prior to being in the
heads world 50 prior to the being the
tails word 50 the fact that there are
more of you in the tales world doesn't
matter
so
hopefully the tension here is a little
bit clear when i described what was
going on in the cosmology context
i think like the more obvious
intuitively appealing thing is the world
first approach you assign a probability
prior probability to a cosmological
scenario and only afterward do you
assume you're typical within that
whereas in the sleeping beauty approach
what seems to be
kind of like most obviously intuitive
is the observer first approach where we
give equal credences to being all of the
observers in all of the different
scenarios
so what this should be teaching us is
we need to think about it and this is
not an obvious set of things to do at
all okay
now it's going to get worse i'm just
going to keep digging holes for us
because remember my goal here is not to
tell you the one once and for all final
answer even though i have some ideas
um but rather it is to explain why this
is such an interesting philosophical
problem
and the problem is
that in either
idea with either the world first
approach assign priors to different
cosmological scenarios and then assume
you're typical within them or the
observer first approach where you assume
you're typical within the set of all
possible observers both of them lead you
to draw conclusions
that in retrospect seem unwarranted okay
so there is a name there is uh something
called the presumptuous philosopher
problem
that arises in the observer first
approach but i think that there are
equally weird problems that arise in
either approach so let me tell you what
the problems are because i think they
they stem from the same mistake
ultimately
in the world first approach so remember
i'm going to keep repeating this because
i know it's hard to keep the jargon
straight the world first approaches i
first assign a credence to the different
scenarios and then i assume i'm i'm
typical within the scenario so the
problem here is that you seem to be
giving yourself leverage over the future
this leads to what is called the
doomsday argument that you predict
imminent demise for
humanity and let me explain what i mean
by that so let the reference class
remember the world first so we have a
reference class we're going to assume
we're typical within it but what we do
is we first assign a prior probability
and then we assume we're typical within
all the observers within that scenario
so let theory a
the small universe theory be a theory in
which there are
200 billion human beings who will ever
live
okay so we can go we go again go to
wikipedia and ask how many human beings
have ever lived in history up to today
the answer is about a hundred billion
so what we're assuming here in theory a
is a cosmological scenario where
about an equal number of human beings
are born in the future it won't take
that long we already have like seven or
eight billion already live so because of
population growth won't take that many
more years before we reach a total of
200 billion and then we imagine some
terrible disaster happens okay
that's theory a that's a cosmological
scenario in a very broad
idea of what qualifies as cosmology
theory b is
humanity is much more successful so
theory a is like humanity's doomed
pretty soon you know in 100 or 200 years
humanity is going to be gone
um theory b says no humanity's going to
flourish for a long time and maybe you
know it will go away but it won't
necessarily go away by dying maybe we'll
transform into something else but who
cares the point is that in theory b the
big universe theory where imagine there
are 200 trillion human beings who will
ever exist so theory a only has 200
billion human beings only twice as many
that actually have existed theory b has
200 trillion so over a thousand times
the number that have already existed
now
those are our two scenarios we have some
prior
that they are uh likely or unlikely what
is the prior well i don't know roughly
speaking but let's assume they're not
too different this is always a problem
with bayesian reasoning as assigning
what the prior credences are supposed to
be but let's assume they're not too
different let's be sufficiently
pessimistic that we say look it's
completely plausible that humanity wipes
itself out within a few centuries right
i think that is plausible so let's let's
give that some prior and let's give the
more successful theory b some other
prior who cares about the exact numbers
they won't be relevant
the point is we have data
in in this scenario in this way of
thinking about things with the world
first scenario we have assigned our
prior and now we update
on the basis of the data what is the
data the data is that we find ourselves
within the first hundred billion
human beings whoever existed okay
and the reasoning is without going into
the numbers the reasoning is in theory a
that data is really likely you know if
there's only 200 billion humans that
will ever exist
the probability that a random human a
typical human is within the first 100
billion is 50 that's pretty darn likely
but in theory b if there are 200
trillion humans then the probability
that you find yourself within the first
100 billion is really small
less than 10 to the minus 3 right
so therefore the logic goes i have i can
now
conclude using reasoning
that theory a is ten to the three times
more likely than i thought it was based
on my prior probabilities
in other words i predict just on the
basis that i am a typical person that
humanity won't last for much longer
that's why it's called the doomsday
argument and brandon carter john leslie
richard gott other people have argued
exactly along these lines
that's the prediction of the observer
first scenario that because we are more
likely uh to have certain qualities if
those qualities are typical we can
reason our way into believing that if
we're
typical life is not going to continue on
for human beings much longer it might
not be a doomsday scenario like maybe we
all get uh uplifted or sublimed into the
matrix or something like that that would
also count but human beings as we know
it are not going to last very long
according to this doomsday reasoning and
richard gott in particular got a lot of
publicity for pushing this this way of
reasoning
there's a very
similar argument that was put forward by
james hartle
and mark fred nikki um where they
consider
two different scenarios one of which is
human beings
with roughly speaking you know 10
billion human beings alive today that's
a little bit larger but okay this is a
round number
human beings are the only life forms
only intelligent life forms in the solar
system right that's the uh theory a
assumption
theory b
is that there are human beings here on
earth but also
the atmosphere of jupiter
is
teeming with life forms with intelligent
beings there's 10 trillion jovians out
there okay
so a thousand times more intelligent
jovians than there are human beings here
on earth that's theory b so two
cosmological scenarios both of which fit
our data that we have you know from
telescopes etc perfectly well we haven't
really explored
the atmosphere of jupiter so we can
assign some priors to these but then
we do reasoning we do logic from this
world first point of view and the idea
would be
in theory a for typical observers well
typical observers would be humans
because theory a says the only observers
in the solar system are humans
under theory b a typical observer
in the solar system would be a jovian
right would be a gas bag floating in the
atmosphere of jupiter
we are not a gas bag floating in the
atmosphere of jupiter therefore we have
good evidence against theory b
because in this way of thinking
and by the way i mean hartle and
trednicki are making this argument to
make fun of it they don't believe this
argument they say surely you don't
believe this what they're saying is we
can
conclude that there probably aren't 10
trillion intelligent gas bags in the
atmosphere of jupiter without ever going
and looking just by sitting in our
armchairs and doing this kind of
reasoning right
and what's going on is that by assuming
that we are typical observers we are
granting ourselves huge amount of
leverage over what a typical observer is
so in other words the way i like to put
it is when you say well i'm a typical
observer principle of mediocrity right
you know it sounds all humble
it sounds like you're not really saying
anything grandiose but if you think
about it
the
proposal that you are a typical observer
in the universe is really proposing the
typical observers in the universe are
like you
typical observers are
roughly in our era of human history
typical observers are here on earth not
in jupiter right
so you're giving yourself enormous
leverage over the rest of the universe
by assuming that there aren't many many
more observers that are not like you
because if there were a typical observer
wouldn't be like you
so this is the worry that this world
first approach which seemed logical when
we first said it out loud is secretly
granting you an enormous amount of
leverage over the universe without ever
getting out of your armchair and looking
at it
so you might say okay i want to fix that
problem
um i don't believe these doomsday
arguments or aliens arguments let's go
to the observer first approach the
observer first approach remember
gives a boost to scenarios that have
more observers in them because you're
saying that you're typical within set of
all observers over all the different
possible scenarios
so if you were
if you give a boost to let's say the
theory where human beings last longer
or a boost to the prior probability the
prior credence to the theory where there
are a lot of aliens on jupiter so in
both
large universe scenarios get more of a
boost and then you conditionalize by
observing that you're in this tiny
little um piece of the universe these
cancel out
okay and so you don't end up helping
yourself to extra reasoning or extra
conclusions about the large universe
but
so in other words the observer first
approach gets rid of the doomsday
argument or the jovian's argument it has
a different problem and this is
technically what bostrom has labeled the
presumptuous philosopher problem so
again let and i'll pick yet another set
of numbers just to be clear about this
um
let's imagine scenario a is some
cosmological scenario with i don't know
um a trillion observers 10 to the 12
observers in it
and cause a scenario b is a big universe
something like 10 to the 21 observers in
it and as far as physics is concerned
they're equally simple these two
scenarios there's no reason to think
that the big universe or the small
universe are favored
precisely as we would say
for
is the universe beyond our horizon
stretching on for infinity or does it
curl up into a sphere or a taurus or
whatever there's no strong huge
difference between those two scenarios
do we live in an infinite universe or a
finite one i could imagine good
arguments for either one i would give
them roughly equal credences if i didn't
have any other information and what
bostrom points out is that if you take
the observer first approach so you give
equal priors or roughly comparable
priors to the small universe in the big
universe but now you say you're a
typical observer within the entire
ensemble then with overwhelming
probability
with probability 10 to the nine or so
with you know one minus ten to the nine
i suppose um you're going to be in the
big universe
because there's more observers in the
big universe therefore you conclude
that
theory b is correct you conclude that
our universe does in fact extend
infinitely far it does not curl up into
a sphere or a torus just because there
are many more observers
in that scenario
and so to bostrom even though he's a fan
of like the doomsday argument he says
that's presumptuous
i don't think that i should be able to
conclude that the universe is big just
from the fact that i exist again without
getting out of my armchair without doing
anything
so
this is the problem as i see it you
started in both cases in the world first
or observer first approach you started
by acting humble by saying yeah i'm just
a typical observer nothing special about
me
but in either way just the assumption
that you are a typical observer has
given you enormous leverage over what
the rest of the universe is like without
going out and looking at it
so the point is that typicality is
actually presumptuous
it is not humble at all the statement i
am typical is the statement that typical
observers are like me
what right do you have to say that that
is saying something really really strong
about the nature of the universe that
you haven't looked at
okay
so this is a problem
this is a problem for anthropic
reasoning this is a problem for
trying to go from a scenario like uh the
cosmological multiverse to a prediction
for the cosmological constant the vacuum
energy right we need to have some
mechanism we need to have some formula
some formalism
that allows us to plug in numbers and
and the good thing about the principle
of typicality was that that's what it
let us do you know let's let us say if
there were there were some different
competing theories of the universe with
different numbers of observers and so
forth we had distributions over what
those observers saw you could make
predictions for what those what we
should see in that scenario and if we
can't assume that we're typical
then how do we make predictions how do
we use anthropic reasoning at all can we
use it at all
so there are a couple of different
solutions to this um and i i want to
talk
about one solution that i don't like
because it's a little i i know why
people do like it you know it's tempting
um but i really want i want to disagree
with it so
this is the point of that heartland
shred nikki paper i'll try to remember
to put you know links to some of these
papers in the show notes um
the heart of lunch for nikki paper
which gave us the issue with the aliens
and the jovians and whatever why was it
doing that it was to argue against
typicality at all that was their point
they thought
and i agree with them this far but not
with their solution to it they thought
that assuming we're a typical observer
is both um unjustified and leads to
incorrect conclusions it's it's too
presumptuous so what is their solution
their solution is what they call a zero
graphic distribution
so what they
say is that when you have a theory a
cosmological theory with many observers
rather than just saying we are a typical
observer in other words we have equal
probability of being any observer in
this universe within some specified
reference class
the theory comes not just with a list of
observers but with a distribution over
those observers and the distribution
over those observers tells you what is
the probability
that you are one of those observers okay
so in other words they consider two
different theories um so here's a
cosmological
scenario that has no boltzmann brains in
it so theory a the small universe theory
has ordinary observers in it people like
you and me who
came to exist after the big bang as a
result of the evolution governed by the
arrow of time et cetera et cetera et
cetera ordinary thermodynamic observers
let's imagine there's some large number
of those 10 to the 40th i don't know i
made up a number and zero boltzmann
brains so let's imagine you know the
universe just settles down there are no
fluctuations no boltzmann brains that's
theory a okay
but then there's theory b
theory b has the same number of ordinary
observers but it also has a ginormous
number of boltzmann brains in it 10 to
the 10 to the 100 or whatever you want
10 to the 10 to the 10 10 of 100 if you
want a large number of boltzmann brains
and we'll get in a little bit to what i
mean exactly by a boltzmann brain
because that's a important question here
but an observer who has randomly
fluctuated into existence that's what i
mean by that for the moment
so the typical cosmologist on the street
when faced with these two scenarios
would say okay there's scenario a only
ordinary observers no boltzmann brains
scenario b that has both and there are a
lot of boltzmann brains and the way that
most cosmologists on the street would
reason is to say
well
i am an ordinary observer
and the probability that i would be an
ordinary observer in theory a is one
all observers in theory a are ordinary
ones so the likelihood function
for being an ordinary observer
conditionalized on theory a being
correct is one
that's the the data is i'm ordinary the
theory is theory a there are no
boltzmann brains whereas in theory b the
probability under the typicality
assumption uh that i would be an
ordinary observer is vanishingly small
10 to the minus 10 to the 100 okay if
theory b were right i would be a
boltzmann brain because most observers
are boltzmann brains
therefore
says the ordinary cosmologist on the
street theory b is ruled out i don't
need to leave my armchair i know that's
not right because if it were right i
would be a boltzmann brain
what heartland for nikki say this is a
very different move than most
cosmologists make they want to say
i don't know
whether theory a or theory b is right
i have not left my armchair and i
shouldn't allow myself to conclude
issues that only have to deal with
things that are far away from my
armchair or any of my other observations
and what but they that's okay
but then they say well i know i'm not a
boltzmann brain
and yet i want to be
in some sense typical but not really so
that's what they solve with this idea of
a zero graphic distribution and so they
say that in addition to theory a saying
there's just ordinary observers no
boltzmann brains theory b saying there's
ordinary observers and boltzmann brains
theory b needs to come along with the
distribution over those observers and
they say well consider the following
distribution within theory b
so theory b has both ordinary observers
and boltzmann brains they say what if my
probability of being a certain kind of
observer
is zero for all the boltzmann brains
and one over the number of ordinary
observers for all the ordinary observers
so i'm typical but only within the
subset of ordinary observers
so they're admitting that there exists
all these boltzmann brains but they're
putting this extra probability
distribution that just says by fiat i am
not one of them
how can they justify doing that well
they look around and they know they're
not one of them
this might be considered cheating right
because you're using your data to define
your theory ahead of time yeah maybe
it's a little cheating but we'll get to
the specific way in which i think this
this fails but the claim is that this
solves the boltzmann brain problem you
know without doing any work so
most cosmologists want to say
if your cosmological scenario predicts
that most observers are boltzmann brains
then your cosmological scenario is wrong
what hartle and schwernicki want to say
is all it shows is that you're not a
boltzmann brain i'm perfectly happy to
consider universes that have lots of
boltzmann brains in them because i can
just say i'm not one of them
that is their move with the zero graphic
distribution okay
here's why i don't think that works i i
really do think that it's cheating
and the reason why it's cheating is a
slightly more nuanced comes from a
slightly more nuanced understanding of
what you mean by a boltzmann brain like
people like literally today on twitter
for no good reason someone is asking
about boltzmann brains and
what counts
as a boltzmann brain like how much
oxygen do you need how much of a body do
you need how long do you need to survive
to be a boltzmann brain
so my point is that none of these
questions matter in any real point
because you can work
the calculation the other way around you
tell me
what you want to count as an observer
okay do you just need a brain do you
need a brain in a body you need a brain
and a body on a planet with an
atmosphere do you need a family and you
need other people to keep you happy do
you need maybe
everything you see so are you an
observer that is literally in exactly
the macroscopic state that you
personally are in right now so what's in
your brain all the things you're seeing
with your eyeballs they're really there
so like let's take all that but the
point is i'm defining all of this stuff
in terms of stuff that exists right now
okay not i'm not i'm not allowed to
include the history of the stuff that
got you there i'm saying here are
different kinds of observers that can
exist at one point in time and we can
basically classify them into two types
there are
third thermodynamically sensible
observers right this is what we call
ordinary observers people like you and
me people who came into existence
through ordinary evolution through
physical processes biology natural
selection etc
from a low entropy past in some sense
the past hypothesis which you've heard
me talk about before the idea that there
was a low entropy passed around 14
billion years ago
that's what gives rise in the immediate
aftermath a few tens of billions of
years after math to thermodynamically
sensible observers
and the thing about those observers is
when they look out at the cosmic
microwave background for example and
they say aha
that's evidence of a low entropy past
and that's literally telling me that the
universe was pretty smooth at very very
early times and therefore low entropy
well there's a secret there there's a
secret
step in that conclusion how do you know
when you look at the universe that the
universe did have a low entropy
the answer is that it's consistent but
it's not implied by any observations we
make if you just say
let's think of all the different
possible ways that photons could hit my
telescope and give me a map of the
cosmic microwave background that looks
like the one we see
most of them do not correspond to
universes where the early times really
were smooth
it's true that
if the early universe was smooth then we
would see what we see in our telescopes
but it's not true that if we see what we
see in our telescopes then the early
universe must have been smooth just
conditionalizing on what we see in our
telescopes and not some extra assumption
about entropy
it is overwhelmingly likely that the
early universe was really really lumpy
wildly inhomogeneous from place to place
but there's a number of different
effects that give rise to the final
wavelength of light when we observe it
there's the density and the temperature
there's also the doppler effect there's
also gravitational redshift and blue
shift etc there's a whole bunch of
effects
and even though it seems really unlikely
it is much more probable that there are
wildly fluctuating things going on all
of which almost exactly cancel out
by the time the photons reach us
and this is just a fancy roundabout way
of saying that given any medium entropy
state
like us here in our telescope looking at
the past
given any medium entropy state there are
many more high entropy pasts from which
it could have evolved via a random
fluctuation
then there are low entropy paths that
would naturally have led to it so i know
i'm repeating myself but this is a
critical and kind of difficult point so
i'll repeat it again
if you start by saying what are the
kinds of early conditions which
naturally would lead to us
the answer is they must have been low
entropy i talked about this with david
wallace on the podcast not too long ago
but if instead you're asking what are
the kinds of conditions
that
naturally would be in the past given
that we're here
you see the difference you're asking a
slightly different question not
what are the kinds of universes
that the kinds of initial conditions
that would usually lead to us
but instead what are the kinds of what
are the total set of universes that
could lead to us okay
so the kinds of universes that could
lead to us kinds of initial conditions
early universe scenarios are
overwhelmingly high entropy and we're
the result of a random fluctuation okay
so all of this was a aside to say
the idea of a thermodynamically sensible
observer is one for whom that's not the
case we did not randomly fluctuate into
existence there the past hypothesis that
says that there's low entropy is correct
and therefore our inferences from the
data about what happened in the past of
our universe are reliable
thermodynamically
sensible and then there's another kind
of observer the generalization of the
idea of a boltzmann brain which we can
call a randomly fluctuated observer okay
so if you don't have a past hypothesis
if you don't insist by assumption
that the early universe had low entropy
all you know is some features of your
current state
then
if you live in a thermal universe that
exists forever if you listen live in
this uh eternal thermally fluctuating
universe it is overwhelmingly likely
that both your past and your future had
higher entropy
and that you represent a random
fluctuation and this has nothing to do
with brains or minimal observers or
anything like that the statement is that
for any conditions on your current
macroscopic self
if that's all you know you don't also
know the past hypothesis if you just
think that you are an element of some
randomly fluctuating ensemble
you have resulted from
a set of wild coincidences cancelling
out
in the past to go from high entropy to
create you okay
and if you live in this universe with
random fluctuations forever the number
of randomly fluctuating observers of any
kind
in other words any macroscopic features
living on earth have a sun have memories
in their heads whatever you want to say
conditions you put on your present self
the number of randomly fluctuating
observers like that
is enormously larger than the number of
thermodynamically sensible observers
like that if you live in this randomly
fluctuating universe
so this is the problem if you really
think about it with the heartland
trednicky
way of wriggling out of the boltzmann
brain problem because they say well i
just
assume by by fiat that i'm not a
boltzmann brain
fine let's imagine that i let you do
that there are still if you live in that
eternally fluctuating cosmology
there are still observers that look
exactly like you
but are random fluctuations by exactly
like you i mean wherever you're sitting
the room around you i'll grant you the
entire earth if you want okay and all of
the light that is coming to the earth
from the sun and the stars and the
planets and whatever all that stuff
i will grant you all that
it is still true
that you are overwhelmingly likely to be
randomly fluctuated into existence
in fact i can continue on i can say like
let's take our past light cone let's
take you and all of your observations
and extend it into the past and assume
that everything you think is true about
your past is true i'm going to grant you
all of that
but i say also
that past that you think you're
observing is not actually
resulting from a uniform universe it's
it's a selection out of an ensemble in a
randomly fluctuating eternal universe
okay
like carl and trednicki want to allow
for they want to say that's okay
so if i give you your entire past and
say conditionalize on observers like
that
they are still likely to be part of a
bigger thermal equilibrium ensemble
which means that tomorrow when you go
out to the telescope and look at the
microwave background it won't be there
anymore it just your previous experience
was just a random fluctuation there's no
reason because
think about it sorry you need to back up
because it's obvious to me but if you
have not really thought about cosmology
and general relativity it's not always
obvious
when we look at the cosmic microwave
background we're looking into the past
right we're using light to observe
conditions far away it takes light time
to reach us and therefore billions of
years have passed since the moment that
this photon that we're observing today
last interacted with the microwave
background
and as time goes on what that means is
there's more and more time between the
formation of the cosmic microwave
background and us
so we're looking
more and more time back at regions of
the cosmic microwave background that
were created slightly further away
the horizon that we have by stretching
our past light cone back to the
microwave background grows gradually
with time as we get older so we're
looking at slightly different portions
of the cosmic microwave background and
the point is if everything that we know
is just a random fluctuation there's no
reason at all for that pattern to
continue
tomorrow we should look out and see no
microwave background at all that would
be the most likely thing most likely way
for the universe to be conditionalized
on our current observations and giving
you everything about the actual past of
our light cone
and i would argue i think that heartland
for dickie would disagree with me um but
i would argue that there is zero
principal reason to exclude observers
like that from your geographic
xerographic distribution if your
motivation for excluding observers was i
only want to
consider observers who had legitimate
fair
inferences from the data
reliable inferences from the past based
on their observations then observers
like i just described are perfectly okay
and there are many many more of them
than ones that came from a universally
low entropy condition at very early
times those observers who would still
see the microwave background there
tomorrow so i would argue that their
theory makes a prediction and their
prediction i mean they made it years ago
so it's been
falsified many many times
in other words the problem is not
boltzmann brains
the problem is boltzmann use the problem
is whoever you are whatever you think
about your current macroscopic state you
could have fluctuated randomly into
existence and if
you believe that the cosmological
scenario is one that is dominated by
random fluctuations then you probably
did fluctuate into existence just like
that and you're trying if you're hard on
true nikki to discriminate against
boltzmann brains but there's no reason
to discriminate against boltzmann use in
that cosmological scenario except
because you just don't like it
you don't want to be a random
fluctuation and therefore you say i deny
that that's what i am
i think there's no principled reason to
do that this is a different version of
the presumptuousness
you're just
assigning a probability to being a
certain observer
not on the basis of any data whatsoever
or any even reasonably chosen
probability distribution but just
because you want a certain conclusion to
be true
and i don't think that's that's not how
science or cosmology or philosophy for
that matter typically works
but
i do think there is a slightly better
way of doing things i don't think it's
the once and for all answer but it sort
of is suggested by the reasoning we just
went through right because at the end
what i was arguing for was there is a
kind of typicality that we really can't
wriggle out of
in the case of these eternally
fluctuating universes there are
boltzmann use right which means that
this is you y-o-u
in case you can't hear my lettering when
i'm talking um
there are random fluctuations with all
of the characteristics of your current
macroscopic self
and even though i was arguing earlier
against thinking that we're typical
instead of all possible observers
if you limit yourself to the set of all
observers
exactly identical to you macroscopically
then i do think you kind of got to be
typical in that sense because you have
no criterion to distinguish between them
so
in the set of all people named sean
carroll who have podcasts called
mindscape et cetera et cetera et cetera
people in the multiverse
with all of the macroscopic features
that i have
if that's all i know i should assign
equal probability to being them there
are
subtleties there with quantum mechanics
and different branches of the wave
function but in a classical ensemble i i
have no reason to assign myself in in
allocating credences in this situation
of self-locating uncertainty i have no
reason to favor some versions of me over
the others i should be typical within
the set of me's
in the universe
and this idea was actually put forward
by radford neal who is a statistician at
the university of toronto and he calls
the idea fully non-indexical
conditioning so what does that mean so
it means you condition over everything
you know about you right so you say i
already know i'm an earthling
whatever you know about yourself you
know your age your gender okay etc
everything you know about you your
memories of the past your observations
of the universe all that counts you can
conditionalize on that
except for where you are in the universe
that's the non-indexical part that's
what you can't conditionalize over
because you don't know it
and so then what you're saying is it's a
very different approach than the typical
cosmologist uses right the typical
cosmologist says well there are
some there is some notion of observers
and i don't know exactly what it means
but they're they're smart people you
know people who can do science whatever
it takes and i'm typical within that set
and that lets me do predictions because
you know if i have a universe or a
multiverse with different values of the
cosmological constant i can ask
questions like you know what do most of
these observers see
the problem with the apparent problem
with fully non-indexical conditioning
was saying i'm only typical within the
people set of people who have exactly my
macroscopic data
is how do i reason
anthropically right
the suggestion is that when you do that
bayesian calculation and you're saying
the probability of the data given the
theory
you interpret that as the probability
that there exists an observer in exactly
your macroscopic configuration which
seems to sort of rule out the
possibility
of
predicting things for like the cosmos
constant because we've already observed
it
people like me know what the cosmos
constant is so there's no extra
prediction to be made so that is a that
is a problem with it so i'm upfront
about what the problems are
but
the problems are far outweighed by the
benefits i think and the benefits are
not 100 which is why i don't think this
is the final answer um but this is
instead of saying you're a typical
observer just saying you are you and
accepting that so taking all of the old
evidence into consideration
what does that lead you to conclude well
let's go back to our presumptuousness
problems right in the world first
approach where you assigned prior
probabilities to different scenarios and
then said you were typical within them
we had the doomsday argument we said uh
well if we're typical human beings then
typical human beings are going to be
within a couple generations of us in the
future and therefore humanity's going to
die okay
well the fully non-indexical approach
says
i am i am me
so i know how many other human beings
there are i know how many years ago
agriculture was invented and the
industrial revolution was etc
and that's the only set within which i'm
typical
so i can conclude nothing about the
existence of either future human beings
or of alien gas bags on jupiter i am not
pretending to be typical within those
sense therefore i can do no reasoning
that gives me any armchair insight into
whether or not i am uh whether or not
those scenarios are legitimate so
from this point of view
there is no um extra benefit to sorry
there is no way for me to say that
humanity will end soon or there are no
aliens on jupiter
what about um
the
boltzmann brain problem if you are a
typical observer right a typical
observer within exactly observers that
have your
data your macroscopic information here i
have to fudge a little bit i'm being i'm
trying to be overly honest i think it's
a perfectly legitimate fudge but i have
to add an extra
principle of thinking about these things
because
by this logic if you live in the
universe which is eternally fluctuating
then indeed most as i just said as i
just tried to explain most observers
with exactly my macroscopic data will be
random fluctuations not um
people who are thermodynamically
sensible so
and furthermore you can go on to say
that the probability
of the existence of someone just like me
will generally be higher
than the probability sorry the
probability exists in someone like me in
a randomly fluctuating eternal universe
is basically one right i mean given the
local laws of physics that we're gonna
keep fixed for this thought experiment
eventually someone like me will randomly
fluctuate into existence
whereas
uh the probability of me existing in a
small universe
right if i just believe in the ordinary
big bang
um with a hot big bang with which makes
hundreds of billions of galaxies but not
an infinite number
then there is some probability of
getting a person like me but it's a
small probability right even if you
think that the probability of getting
life somewhere in the universe is pretty
large the probability of getting exactly
me is pretty small
so
much like the
observer first approach
this approach does give a little bit of
a boost
to larger universes because what i'm
saying is what is the probability of
someone like me coming into existence so
it's not the total number of observers
that counts for its own sake it's the
probability of me existing that counts
and a larger universe has a larger
probability of me existing so therefore
for the boltzmann brain problem i need
to worry why am i not a boltzmann brain
and the fudge is the following
i believe that i can't believe that i am
a boltzmann brain
that's the problem the problem is as i
talked about in this paper i wrote why
boltzmann brains are bad cognitive
instability of the boltzmann brain
scenario so as i said if you believe in
this scenario with random fluctuations
causing observers to come into existence
all sorts of observers will randomly
fluctuate into existence
and including
in fact dominated by
observers who are completely wrong about
everything so observers who have
thoughts and beliefs both about the
empirical situation in the universe and
also about the laws of physics and the
laws for that matter of logic and
reasoning and and science
but all of those thoughts about all
those principles and pieces of data
randomly fluctuated into their brains
so here's the problem
if you
use logic and reason
conclude that you are probably a
boltzmann fluctuation
then you must also think that you have
no right to believe
any of the steps you used along the way
to do that reasoning because all those
steps were based on principles of logic
and reasoning that just randomly
fluctuated into your brain
so this is a different kind of thing
what i would therefore say is
in order to be consistent in thinking
about this
i have to modify the prior
probability that i put in these
scenarios by some sort of cognitive
factor a factor that says
i'm not going to give any prior
probability or essentially none maybe
some
incredibly tiny number
to scenarios in which people like me
would get everything wrong
because i want to try to get everything
right so i can't reason my way into
saying i'm not a boltzmann brain but i
can reason myself way my way into saying
i shouldn't believe
i'm a boltzmann brain and what that
means is i shouldn't consider
cosmological scenarios in which i should
be a boltzmann brain
did that make sense anyway the point is
the reason why i would argue
we should give zero credence to
boltzmann brain-dominated cosmologies is
not because we look around and see we're
not boltzmann brains that's just what a
boltzmann brain would say
it's not internally consistent to say
that
rather we should rule them out a priori
on just principles of reasoning and if
you think that's presumptuous it's only
presumptuous if you think that you might
actually be a boltzmann brain which i
don't think that anyone really thinks
that they are
uh certainly i'm not advocating that you
do think that i'm just advocating that e
we concentrate as working cosmologists
on developing cosmological scenarios in
which most observers like me are not
boltzmann brains and like you also at
the same time
therefore i just need to assume as a
principle of reasoning that my reasoning
is relatively reliable in other words
okay then the final issue that we have
to get uh off the table here if this is
the principles we're adopting this sort
of um fully
non-indexical conditioning uh reasoning
that we are typical only within the set
of people exactly like ourselves
then how do we do the anthropic
principle how do we make predictions
about things like the cosmological
constant etc
so i claim that in fact if you think
about it carefully the usual anthropic
reasoning goes through as long as you
don't
make the mistake which i think is just a
logical mistake of using the fact you
already know the cosmological constant
so if you think that we already know the
value of the cosmological constant uh
you're not really predicting its value
you have to sort of temporarily pretend
that we don't know and then you imagine
asking yourself the question what would
i predict in different cosmological
scenarios okay
and the point is that
for better or for worse this idea that
you
have the probability of you existing be
how you interpret the probability of the
data given the theory
roughly speaking the probability of you
existing is going to be proportional to
the number of observers right because if
we rule out these eternal
infinitely fluctuating universes
then
uh
the more observers we have
in a universe
that is doing all sorts of things the
more likely it is to land on exactly an
observer like you so roughly this will
sort of saturate right if you get to
enough observers that there's probably
more than one observer like you then you
stop giving an extra bonus to large
universes but if you're comparing a
universe where the probability of u is
10 to the minus 10 to the universe where
the probability of u is 10 to the minus
1 you would give a bonus to the
probability being 10 to the minus 1 of
an observer like you and i think that's
okay actually right i don't think it's a
mistake to favor universes that predict
like observers that observers like me
probably will exist and if you take that
attitude then if you then imagine that
you apply this problem to
a set of different
sub-universes within the cosmological
multiverse and those sub-universes have
different values of the cosmological
constant
then you're basically doing exactly what
stephen weinberg did back in 1988 he in
fact literally used the number of
observers who would measure the
cosmological constant as a proxy for the
prior
for the probability of being of
measuring that value and then he used
the number of galaxies as a proxy for
the number of observers so i think in
other words that
adopting this strategy of saying the
only thing that we're typical within the
only set of observers within which we
are typical is the set of observers just
like me
still gives the same anthropic
predictions as the typical street
cosmologist would get
remember that i started the whole
discussion by saying that physicists
were very happy to get the right answer
using the wrong reasoning and i think
that in many cases in
the anthropic
scenario and the anthropic principle
applied to cosmology that's exactly what
is going on i think they are getting the
right answer but for the wrong reasons
okay
final thing final issue is the other
kind of presumptuousness so i i
mentioned the presumptuousness of the
doomsday argument etc and said that
assuming that i am typical only within
people like me eliminates that
presumptuousness it gets us out of that
problem remember the other kinds of
presumptuousness was somehow giving too
much of a bonus
to big universes that's what bostrom
complained about in the uh
observer first approach and i think that
this approach is actually closer to the
observer first approach by by it does
give an extra little bump to universes
with lots of people in them because the
probability of getting me is larger not
because i'm sort of a priori
favoring universes with lots of people
but i'm favoring universes that predict
me
and i think that i think that's okay i
don't think that's presumptuous at all
it does kind of match nicely with the
thirder position in the sleeping beauty
problem right so maybe at the end of the
day it's all consistent so naively the
probability of you in a large universe
is much much larger than the probability
of you in a small universe therefore you
should allow yourself to conclude
that
if you have
competing cosmological scenarios which
are similar
physically similar so they have similar
priors that we want to give them but
differing the number of observers you
should favor
the uh scenario with more observers in
it and i think in in radford neal's
paper he kind of fudges about this a
little bit he doesn't quite bite the
bullet and say that that's true
i think maybe it is this is my tentative
place that i'm landing on that it is
okay
to favor universes with lots of
observers and therefore have a larger
probability of predicting me
if you're considering a bunch of
universes with effectively an infinite
number of observers it doesn't matter so
this is where to me it's a difference
between a fully non-indexable fully
non-indexable conditioning and the more
traditional self-indication assumption
aka the observer first approach
because in that approach you would
really give a boost
depending on how many observers there
were full stop
here in this approach you're just giving
a boost depending on the probability of
you coming into existence right so the
point is that if the probability of that
happening is low
then it will be roughly proportional to
the number of observers you know
basically you have a chance that each
observer is just like you so the more
observers you have the more the
probability is that you'll get you
but once the number of observers becomes
so large that people like you are almost
inevitable
i don't give an extra boost to creating
a billion versions of you versus
creating one version of you in either
case the probability of the theory
predicting the existence of you is of
order one okay so the the boost to large
universes saturates at some value in
this way of doing things
is it the right way of doing things
i do not know i need to think about this
i've been thinking about this um i it is
my tentative conclusion my tentative way
of thinking i'm pretty happy with it but
um look this is hard this is what i
started saying you know i can't do an
experiment that easily answers these
questions um
we need to think as carefully as
possible and be as honest and rigorous
as possible about our reasoning that
gets us there and you know one way i
started with
saying the different strengths and
weaknesses of philosophers versus
physicists another way of characterizing
the difference is just
patience
physicists are much less patient than
philosophers physicists want to get to
the answer and they want to get there
expeditiously and philosophers are much
more patient about thinking like what
does every term mean in this sentence
and whatever and look
that's not an unalloyed good thing right
you can get bogged down in arguing over
details of terminology and whatever and
therefore not get to the answer so again
i reiterate that the approach favored by
physicists and the approach favored by
philosophers both have their places here
is a place where the questions we're
asking are clearly physics questions but
the methodologies would benefit from
careful philosophical analysis
that's what i like doing that's fun i
now have a job that lets me do that um
as i'm recording this i'm not there yet
but i'm packing things into boxes
so soon it will all be very official i'm
very excited about it
uh this is just one little example of
the kinds of things that are interesting
to think about at this interface between
physics and philosophy or science and
philosophy more general more generally
i'm thinking very excitedly about still
about quantum mechanics
space-time
the emergence of space-time the
emergence of other things the emergence
of causality the emergence of
consciousness or societies or economics
or complexity you know there's many many
sets of questions that just don't fit
easily into disciplinary boxes and now i
am uh empowered to spend my time
thinking about those things i can't wait
thanks for hanging in there with me
see you next week bye
[Music]
you